i was actually watching a scene of you
um
before i did the segment the woman is in
the tunnel she's a cyclist
and you're talking her through it
i'm like i know it's very dramatic
but also i was just like god if i'm i
just you were so
calming and
connected and in it and empathetic and
yet
telling her it wasn't her time i was
just wrapped
oh thank you so much oh you're so good
you're always so good and um your
husband is in this show as well and you
guys this is your third series together
yes
yeah um he plays a really bad guy in
9-1-1 but it was lots of fun for us we
had a great time getting to do it and it
was nice because we had to do some
really scary scenes and you know we
obviously trust each other so much that
it made it really nice that it was him
well like hashtag roleplay fun at work
you know i actually got to murder him
which was kind of crazy
hey
there's no therapy yeah exactly that's
cathartic and sexy
i don't know but fun um
i um if it's okay i wanted to ask you
some
things um about fun facts with you
yes all right it's fun facts with
jennifer love hewitt
okay
um you love to salsa dance
yes i do
like hard and sexy and cool did you when
did you learn
well i have a big butt so i had to
figure out something to do with it and
salsa dancing was a natural fit
um and i started doing it when i was a
teenager like i would go to these places
where you could you know go and take the
salsa lesson and then they'd bring the
dj out and then use salsa for the night
um and so i've been doing it forever and
i just love it so much it's really fun
well and i don't know if you noticed but
butts have been on trend for the last 20
years so that's right that's right
um
you always find a dairy queen um when
you travel
i do yeah i'm from texas originally and
so dairy queen is a really big deal for
me growing up and uh yeah it's my it's
my thing i always find a dairy queen and
have an ice cream cone and some chicken
fingers it's my
my favorite
jennifer love hewitt at the dq i'm in
uh you've been to japan 15 times
yes
i
did commercials and had an album out
there when i was 12.
um and so i toured there and and went
there a lot to perform and they i
absolutely love it they're so amazing i
haven't been in a really long time and i
really can't wait to go back one day um
but yeah i love it it was fun uh you do
card tricks
um i had to learn card tricks for this
movie that i did in my 20s called
heartbreakers yeah and so i have two
that i can do and i bring them out
whenever possible because i don't have a
lot of other talents and so that's my
thing like if i have the tequila i do a
card trick and that's the way that it
works and you have all the talents
um you like afternoon teas and different
geographies around the world
i do i will always find a hotel that
does an afternoon tea and my daughter's
really into it now too so um we do it
together obviously we haven't been
traveling lately
so we've been doing teas at home where
we get dressed up and we put out all the
proper things and um my friend makes the
scones and we order the tea and we do
the little cakes and sandwiches and the
whole thing and yeah we love it we love
it my daughters just got into cucumber
cream cheese on white bread is there
anything good no there is not anything
better you read a horoscope every day
i do
i do and i am the person who literally
like watches out all day for everything
that it told me to happen and if it
doesn't i'm like oh gotta try again
tomorrow
i love it though i love a little
guidance i love these guys
for signs absolutely i definitely think
that's a girl thing too i don't know how
it is for men but we all are looking for
signs do you have a favorite uh
astrologer it's called astrology zone
susan miller
yes
obsessed i know she's not kind of the
she's she's always right it's kind of
amazing i know it's it's crazy
um and also you're friends with betty
white
yes
a national treasure betty white and you
guys have pizza and vodka nights
yes pizza and vodka is her favorite she
also loves hot dogs
um and she cheats at scrabble horribly
um but she's betty white so you just let
her win
and yeah and one of the only times that
i've been like super drunk was with
betty
in public and she like veered off into a
bush and i thought oh my gosh i'm gonna
kill the national treasure betty white
um and we had to pay and then she loves
to like end her nights with you by like
eating gummy bears i mean it's it's
she's everything you want her to be in
more she's the best and i just love her
to pieces well you are everything um
that we would want you to be and more
jennifer loves you
thank you for coming on the show please
i when the
world is safe to move around about the
cabin of the globe
i would love nothing more than to have
any one of those favorite fun facts
about
with you
yes me too me too please i'm gonna hold
you to that i would love that i was
about to say it's a date okay everybody
911 airs every monday 8 7 central on fox
it's the hugest hit show you already
know it we'll be right back thank you
jennifer love he went
[Music]